So we saw how our two form of the verb to come to eat
to tolerate how would to tolerate be?
Toleration
Toleracion, tolerar.
Exactly, tolerar.
Good.
So our two form ends with an R and it's always gonna be AR
ER or IR and we had an example of each.
And we noticed that for ar, er, and ir verbs, unless the verb is irregular, we will take off that ending.
and put on an O to get the I version to say I tolerate for example so how would you say I tolerate
Tolero?
Good, Tolero.
And you moved the accent back as well, which is essential for the present tense.
Very good.
If you said Tolero, it would mean he tolerated.
Which as I mentioned would be useful for us later when we learn this tense.
But it's important in the present tense to have the accent on the penultimate syllable, tolero.
What was to eat?
Comer.
And what is I eat?
Comero.
So you don't add on the O, you take off the ending.
Oh yes, and then you put como good.
This also means how or like by coincidence.
You might have heard como estas.
How are you?
But como also I eat
So for all verbs we take off the ending and we add or and we get the I version.
But for the rest of the versions, for he, she, euphormen, for we etc.
The verbs split into two groups.
Although we have three different endings, we have two groups.
Now most verbs in Spanish are our verbs.
This is the biggest group, the group of R verbs, the verbs that end AR.
In fact, any new verb that comes into Spanish will become will be crowned as an R verb
So to give you some examples, tweet they are.
What do you think that means?
To Twitter.
To tweet, yes, tweet they are.
Facebook ER Yes this exists.
Google R.
Excellent.
So there is something in the mental lexicon, in the mental dictionary, that's saying there can be no more error verbs.
These are a historic group.
The door is closed.
So we have two groups.
So for r, er, ir, if the verb is regular, we take off the ending, r, er, ir, and we put o and we get the i version.
Now for the others, the other versions, there's a slight difference between r-verbs and er-ir verbs.
Now r verbs have the vowel a as a principal sound.
That's a sound that keeps popping up
So for example to eliminate how is to eliminate elimination elimination eliminar good eliminar so if you want to say I eliminate or I delete
How would it be?
Think syllable by syllable.
If you think of it all together, it's quite confusing here because you have quite a few vowels.
Good.
You see when you when you take your time to divide actually the word piece by piece, it's much more digestible.
Ellimino, good.
Now for he, she, it, a new formal, we've learned that these group together in Spanish.
We just use an A on the ending.
So how would that be?
He deletes or eliminates she, he, you form a Elimina.
Good.
And we still have the accent on the penultimate syllable.
Elimina.
Very good.
How do you think you would say to last, like it lasts a long time, or something like this?
It's not obvious through the word last, but maybe we find something through Latin that helps us work out how to say that
A period of time sometimes we call it duration.
No?
Yeah.
So how would that be in Spanish?
So to last might actually come from this.
If it did, how would it sound?
Durar.
Yes, and this is this is the verb durar.
A lot is much in Spanish, it's mucho.
So if you want to say it lasts a long time, you can just say it lasts much.
Durar mucho.
This is uh two last durar.
So how would it lasts be
So you would do the same.
Dura mucho.
So you might be talking about a show, a movie.
How would you say it doesn't last a long time?
Notura mucho.
Good, not uramcho.
How do you say exaggeration?
Exag exaggeration.
Exageración.
To exaggerate.
Exagerar.
Yeah.
So how would you say I exaggerate?
Exagero.
Good.
He's exaggerating or she's exaggerating or you.
Exagera.
Good.
He's not exaggerating, she's not exaggerating.
You
Too formal are not exaggerating
No exagera.
Good.
Did you ever hear the word mastication in English?
Masticacion.
Did you ever hear it?
Yeah.
I didn't.
I mean this is a word chewing.
Yes.
So how do you think to chew would be?
Masticar.
Masticar is to chew.
Now I didn't know this word actually, and this will happen to many English speakers as well.
You will be able to work out many English words that you didn't know before through Spanish.
So this was the way around it worked for me because
I found masticar first and then I saw in English somewhere mastication.
So it can work that way around as well, which is useful.
Another example is a morder, which means to bite.
I learned this in Spanish then and then I saw in some uh a novel I was reading, modent.
Oh okay, that means biting.
You can increase your English vocabulary and what you understand in English just through the Latin that you learn in Spanish
So if masticar is to chew, how would you say I chew?
Mastiko.
Mastico.
Good.
And he choose or she choose, it choose, you fumal choo.
Mastika.
Good.
Now this is our key sound, this A sound.
Now we can add on different sounds
to this a to get other versions.
So for example, if we add on an N to this A, we get they and we get U plural.
So in English like you guys, you all, so
How would you say collaboration?
Collaboration.
Collab.
To collaborate?
Collaborar.
Good.
I collaborate.
Colaboro.
Good.
Collaboro.
He, she, it, you women.
Collabora.
You can add on to this an N and you get they or U plural.
So how will it be?
Colaboran.
Good.
Hablar is to speak in Spanish.
Hablar.
It's spelled H A B L A R.
What's happening with that H?
But silent.
Totally silent.
Ablar.
How do you say I speak?
Ablo.
So ablo is I speak or I'm speaking.
Abla is
He, she, it, or um the formal.
Good, you formal.
Good.
So what would it mean if I said no hablan con Pablo?
No hablan con Pablo?
They're not speaking with Pablo.
Good.
They're not speaking with Pablo or they don't speak with Pablo.
How would you say I want to speak?
Quiero hablar.
How would you say I'm going to speak?
Think of to go on a voyage.
Ah, voy.
Good.
Yes.
Voy a blar.
Now I'm not sure because hablar starts with a I'm not sure if you put the a to connect them.
Did you?
Oh no, I didn't.
Voy a hablar.
Good.
And when you speak quickly, it will kind of blend together.
Voy hablar.
Maybe it's a fraction longer, boy hablar, but it will stick together like this.
Good.
Now if we go back to this he she it form and we add an S, we get the U informal
So this is speaking to one person informally.
Ablas.
When we have one of these little words, te me
Lo, los, la, las.
They will come before the changed verb.
So the changed verb is the one that isn't ending R anymore.
They will come before this verb.
So if we have quiero, I want, and we want to say I want it, that it must come before the verb.
So how would it be?
Lo quiero.
But that little word can also go after the complete verb.
If we say something like I want to see it, we end up actually having an option where we put that it.
But it doesn't matter, there's no change in meaning.
It's exactly the same.
You just have the option.
So what was to see, which was related to English view
Ver?
Ver.
So if you want to say I want to see it or I want to see him.
So it's quiero verlo.
Quiero verlo.
Or
Lo quiero ver.
Yeah, you have that option.
But if you have one changed verb all by itself, you don't have the option.
It must go before.
You might say it's important to speak about it.
Now you don't need to say about in Spanish, you're going to say to speak it.
And that's understood to speak about it.
So here in that clause in that bit to speak about it is only to speak.
So how would you say it's important to speak about it or literally it's important to speak it
It's important to hablar lo.
Good.
So how was I must or I owe, which is related to the English word debt?
Debo.
So I must invite him.
Debo invitarlo.
Or lo tepo invitar.
Good.
So that's that's the deal with these little words where we can put them.